this is the moment a russian strike hit
a line of people queuing for
humanitarian aid
six people died
one day on there's four more deaths and
three injured in a similar strike
outside this
clinic the crater the strike left is
small
shrapnel and ball bearings shatter the
windows leaving bullet-like holes
it's alleged russia is using cluster
munitions
a few hundred meters away we find
evidence they are right outside a school
this rocket still in the ground
i was inside i was in school
the shilling has started i could see
through the window it was all red
it was going on for about 10 minutes
when i came out you see that cluster
exploded down there on the pavement
a lot of shrapnel hit the building
smashed the windows of the school
i don't know where it came from
i was inside
that's where the bomb exploded
there's no military in this area it's
residential
one of the impacts was here right in the
middle of the children's playground and
you can see the damage that's been done
across
this children's play area i can see it
on the wood
on the stairs but also
look what it's done to the metal on this
slide
it's cut straight
through
now no children were hurt
but
this could have been
fatal
we found these small pieces of metal
scattered and lodged into the play space
lethal shrapnel that has no place in the
residential area
let alone in a children's playground as
albeg al-jazeera kharkiv